allez un mois de théâtre et de musique à
Versailles c'est le moins Molière dans
quelques instants il y a Debussy va
recevoir le directeur des affaires
culturelles de la ville de Versailles
mais d'abord les explications sur notre
manifestation
comment sinon et
théâtre musique danse cirque les arts de
la Seine revisité par l'esprit de la
comédien sont à l'honneur tout le mois
de juin à Versailles dans le cadre du
moins Molière plus de 300 spectacles
investissent la cité royale des lieux
phares tel les grandes et petites
écuries du château ou plus insolites
comme les parcs place et jardins
redonnent au théâtre populaire toutes
ces lettres de noblesse
le moins Molière 2013 est sous le signe
de la création à l'instar de Viva la
comedia compagnie en résidence à
Versailles qui rejoindra ensuite les
planches du Festival Off d'Avignon
sont jouées ici et c'est notre
avant-poste d'Avignon après on va au
Festival d'Avignon donc on fait ce grand
festival et on a à Versailles un public
qui est très agréable car il a une part
d'exigence et en même temps un accueil
quand même qui est très qui est généreux
et ouvert donc on a un bon baromètre de
ce qui va se passer Avignon
cherchez plutôt un objet qui de votre
amour oral dignité
plusieurs nouveautés sont au programme
la tragédie fera ses premiers pas dans
le festival avec Antigone de Sophocle le
hip-hop et le beatbox rencontreront la
commedia dell'arte et enfin un nouveau
lieu de représentation sera inauguré en
la chapelle Hoche pour trois lectures
inédites
essentiellement en Entrée Libre cette
18e édition démontre un nouveau
l'engagement du festival pour le
développement d'un renouveau des arts de
la Seine accessible à tous
allez le mercredi c'est l'acronique
culture avec vous Aurélia domicile on va
parler théâtre et musique et oui alors
avant de parler hip-hop au sonorités
donc jeux vidéo ce dont on parlait en
tout début d'émission avec donc pandawan
à côté de moi et j'ai plus en face du
groupe Magic mushroom voilà donc
exactement j'ai dévoilé une partie mais
pas tout on garde la surprise pour après
donc nous partons déjà dans la
découverte du moins Molière et pour nous
en parler nous recevons donc ce soir
Yoann Hubert de Love donc vous êtes le
directeur des affaires culturelles à
Versailles alors déjà première question
Jean que j'ai envie de vous poser ce
festival quel est son concept
c'est un festival qui dure un mois déjà
c'est important son conseil d'où le nom
le Mois Molière voilà en fait pendant un
mois on défend le tas de populaire c'est
à dire que pendant tout le mois de juin
toute personne peut trouver à Versailles
tous les soirs du théâtre de la musique
de la danse
cirque et ce de manière gratuite pour la
plupart des spectacles voilà donc c'est
n'est pas que du théâtre en effet c'est
à dire que la programmation
professionnelle c'est essentiellement du
théâtre c'est vraiment la vitrine du mot
Molière et ensuite vous avez toute la
partie off du Mois Molière donc là ce
sont par contre les compagnies locales
de théâtre de musique de danse qui sont
là en amateurs qui présentent leur
création mais la partie la plus
importante ce sont des professionnels
qui viennent de toute la France parfois
de l'étranger qui sont sélectionnés sur
des critères artistiques et qui viennent
présenter leurs créations au Mois
Molière donc c'est quand même
essentiellement de théâtre dont on parle
parce que vous parlez un effet de cette
année l'accent est vraiment mis sur les
créations il y en a 25 je crois 25
créations et certaines d'entre elles
vont rejoindre les planches du Festival
d'Avignon la plupart la plupart d'entre
elles en fait ça veut dire qu'on a tout
un ensemble de compagnies auxquelles on
fait confiance qui sont vraiment dans
cette lignée du théâtre populaire que
qu'on défend chaque année à Versailles
et qu'on défend même tout au long de
l'année et qui du coup viennent à
Versailles pour nous présenter en
exclusivité leur création et ensuite par
ta Avignon donc à partir de début
juillet donc ça permet d'avoir un bon
avant goût d'Avignon en ce qui concerne
toutes les formes de théâtre populaire
ce qui est du coup aussi pour le public
un gage de qualité suppose
si elle n'est pas de qualité bon c'est
bête à dire mais elle plonge
économiquement donc il faut que son
spectacle soit vraiment de vraiment de
qualité et c'est vrai que pour ça que le
Mois Molière est reconnu pour cela alors
on vous parliez de création de de
création locale aussi c'est ça puisque
le Mois Molière c'est aussi l'occasion
de mettre en lumière ces fameuses
résidences qui sont à Versailles toute
l'année ça c'est vraiment la nouveauté
depuis deux trois ans c'est que
certaines compagnies avec lesquelles on
a une tradition de travail vraiment
importante qui sont complètement dans
notre lumière artistique de renouveau du
théâtre populaire c'est compagnies on
les a fait venir à Versailles et on les
a installés en résidence alors c'est le
cas de vive à la comédienne c'est le
dont on a vu des images tout à l'heure
c'est le cas de burlesque associés c'est
le cas de l'Académie Internationale des
Arts du spectacle qui forment des jeunes
acteurs et qui est dirigé par carlobosso
qui a un grand maître de la comédien
c'est le cas de la compagnie méli-mélo
qui est qui fait du cirque du nouveau
cirque donc ses compagnies voilà elles
sont venues à Versailles et les
maintenant elles travaillent toute
l'année à Versailles toute l'année non
seulement elle crée leur spectacle mais
aussi elles interviennent dans les
prisons dans les écoles dans les
hôpitaux dans les maisons de retraite
ensuite au Mois Molière elle nous montre
ce qu'elle nous en préparé elle me
montre ce pourquoi elles ont travaillé
pendant toute l'année puis elle partait
à Avignon et ensuite elles reviennent
elles partent dans toute la France mais
aussi elles irriguent tout le territoire
autour de Versailles puisque la
communauté d'agglomération de versa
grand parc leur permet de diffuser leur
création sur le territoire de
l'agglomération donc c'est tout un
ensemble en fait d'actions que la ville
et la communauté d'agglomération ont mis
en place autour du festival pour aider
ses compagnies et d'une manière générale
pour soutenir la création et le théâtre
populaire
alors en effet l'accent est important
pour vous cet engagement pour le
développement de ce théâtre populaire
l'idée d'une d'une démocratisation de
l'accès à la culture et alors moi je
vous propose qu'on regarde peut-être un
teaser que vous aviez prêt vous avez
préparé la ville de Versailles pour
donner un peu le ton de ce Mois Molière
on regarde
comment était
aujourd'hui non défendu
alors Yoann tiret de l'off est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quel public vous
attendez et bien tous les publics
justement non c'est toujours le la
grande problématique de la culture
effectivement que c'est souvent très dur
toucher tous les publics certains
publics qui sont pas du tout
familiarisés avec la culture ou qui
n'ont pas envie d'y aller et nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que sont le théâtre qui
est pas forcément un art accessible qui
est parfois un art assez élitiste un art
assez fermé ou incompréhensible et bien
qu'on montre que ce théâtre justement
peut être ouvert à tous les publics en
fait ce que quand françois de Mazières
qui est merdes Versailles a fondé ce
festival il y a 18 ans son envie c'était
que les familles puissent revenir au
théâtre puisqu'elles n'y vont plus voilà
c'était son constat et c'est la raison
aussi pour laquelle justement ce théâtre
fassait ses différentes représentations
n'ont pas lieu que dans des lieux
prestigieux des lieux phares comme par
exemple les grands des petites écuries
du château mais également sur des dans
des espaces urbains des parcs des
jardins au cœur des quartiers dans tous
les quartiers dans tous les quartiers de
Versailles c'est vraiment en fait la
définition même du tas de populaire
c'est que c'est un théâtre pour tous ces
deux partout donc par exemple là comme
il y a del arte illustre très bien cela
c'est un théâtre qu'on peut lire à
plusieurs niveaux d'interprétation les
enfants vont voir des jongleries vont
voir des choses très très amusantes très
ludique et on peut voir après un niveau
beaucoup plus artistique beaucoup plus
politique même que certains vont
percevoir et d'autres non donc
finalement c'est un théâtre qui quel que
soit notre origine notre nationalité
notre provenance sociale etc on y trouve
un intérêt parce que finalement c'est un
thème qui nous reflète qui reflète la
société dans toute sa diversité alors on
a rencontré justement des des
Versaillais pour leur poser la question
et quel est donc leur avis sur le Mois
Molière
je trouve que le moi Molière c'est très
bien c'est dommage que il soit gâté par
le temps
je pense que c'est une bonne initiative
culturelle qui permet justement de
remettre cet écrivain au goût du jour le
bac de français arrive je pense que pour
les lycéens ça peut servir beaucoup de
bien c'est je vois avec plaisir mes
enfants qui vont régulièrement en plus
pas simplement moi donc c'est bien
moi qui habite à Versailles depuis 5-6
ans je trouve que à chaque fois la ville
se dynamise beaucoup avec le Mois
Molière notamment à l'école d'archi ou
il y a plein d'événements qui
s'organisaient avec ça enfin pendant ce
mois et avec des étudiants et non
franchement je trouve que c'est une très
très bonne initiative de de la ville et
que ça continue
j'ai très bien c'est toujours très bien
sont plutôt contents alors cette année
c'est la 18e édition vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure quels sont les nouveautés
alors les nouveautés essentiellement
trois grandes nouveautés déjà un nouveau
lieu on ouvre la chapelle Hoche une
magnifique chapelle classique avec un
trio de lecture une déclamation baroque
Muriel Mayet la directrice de la Comédie
Française qui vient nous parler de
Tchekhov et
Eric Orsenna l'académicien qui vient
faire une lecture autour de Le Nôtre
puisque c'est l'année le nôtre une
nouveauté également c'est l'introduction
de la tragédie dans la cour des grandes
écuries pour montrer que la tragédie
elle aussi peut être peut-être populaire
donc c'est vendredi samedi voilà
Antigone et la transition avec le sujet
suivant sera parfaite si j'ai bien
compris puisque cette année on introduit
du hip-hop et de Human Beatbox dans la
comédie del arte c'est une troupe qui
nous vient de Lyon et qui va nous faire
un mélange assez sympathique assez
détonnant la semaine prochaine vendredi
samedi dimanche prochain dans les
irrévérencieux
tout justement ce week-end alors
qu'est-ce que quel est le programme
alors ce week-end on commence les grands
moments c'est aux grandes écuries
vendredi soir et samedi soir donc
Antigone par la compagnie du catogan
vendredi soir on a également un copie
copy c'est un auteur argentin
contemporain donc la nuit de Madame
Lucienne samedi soir au petites écuries
Jean-Paul Sartre les mains sales un
grand classique ensuite dimanche aux
grandes écuries Zadig de Voltaire et
puis samedi et dimanche de partout dans
toute la ville dans les jardins dans les
parcs puisqu'on veut vraiment ce qu'on
disait un théâtre inséré dans le
quotidien les créations de komia Del
Arte de Carlo Bosso donc Beaumarchais
Marivaux Molière Shakespeare enfin là il
y en a vraiment pour tous les goûts au
pied des immeubles au pied des maisons
c'est peut-être de se reporter à votre
site internet tout simplement
voilà l'intégralité de la programmation
mais en tout cas merci beaucoup donc on
rappelle que moi Molière c'est jusqu'au
30 juin et donc le programme a consulté
et en tout cas quasiment tous les soirs
des représentations et de la variété de
la diversité
merci beaucoup merci